بورصه مكاسب روسيا في اوكرانيا تتراجع رغم
الاستراتيجيه الجديده تقول صحيفه واشنطن
بوست الامريكيه التي اعتبرت ان هدف
الكراملين المبكر المتمثل بالاستيلاء على
كافه الاراضي الاوكرانيه كانت طموحا جدا
وسرعان ما تغيرت المعادله لانها لم تتوقع
ان يستمر الصراع طويلا وما اعاقت تقدم
روسي هو عدم استعداد موسكو للقتال لفترات
طويله البيانات الصادره عن معهد دراسه
الحرب اظهرت انه بعد التقدم الروسي في
الاسابيع الاولى من الحرب لم تكسب روسيا
اكثر من الف ميه المربع في اسبوع منذ
ابريل استعاده اوكرانيا منطقه خيرسون بعد
انسحاب موسكو اكبر انتصار لكاف في الحرب
حتى الان وثالث ضربه لروسيا بعد انسحاب
قواتها من الشمال في ابريل ثم من حركات في
سبتمبر بعد الفشل في الاستيلاء على كاف
كان الكرام يملك ميدانيا وحدات سيئه
التجهيز واسطهم في بدايه العديد من موارده
وبعد ان فقدت روسيا موادها في اوكرانيا
وصلت الى مرحله باتت غير قادره فيها على
تحقيق اي مكاسب كبيره وفق ما جاء في تقرير
واشنطن بوست بورصه مكاسب روسيا بعد ان
ارتفعت تراجعت قبل الحرب سيطره موسكو على
نحو 17 الف ميل مربع من اراضي اوكرانيا
ومن ضمنها شبه جزيره القرم التي ضمها
الكريم من خلال العام 2014 والمناطق التي
يسيطر عليها الانفصاليون في دونات ولك الا
انه هو بحلول نهايه الاسبوع الرابع من
الحرب سيطره روسيا على نحو 51 الف ميل
المربع اي
22% من اوكرانيا وما حصل بعد السابع عشر
من نوفمبر هو ان روسيا بات توسيطر على نحو
40 الف من المربع فيما يمثل نحو 17 بالمئه
من البلاد وهي اقل نسبه تسيطر عليها اوسكو
منذ ابريل
[موسيقى]